Speaker 1: Let's do some media news over the
4th of July weekend.
There was such major media news.
It has shaken the media world to its very
core.
Jordan Peterson, who has previously said he's
not political and he's certainly not right
wing, is joining the new right wing online
network, The Daily Wire.
The Daily Wire is apparently now launching
their.
I would.
It's weird.
It's not even really like.
It's all streaming.
It's all online.
Anyway, they're launching something called
Daily Wire Plus.
And I don't know if plus means it's better
or it's sort of like the dregs that nobody
wants.
But anyway, it's Daily Wire.
Plus, Jordan Peterson is going to have a program
on The Daily Wire.
Plus the the a trailer for this program looks
like it would be a parody of what you would
expect to see from someone like Jordan Peterson.
I watched this thing twice and I rarely even
remotely entertained by this stuff.
But this is just wacky.
The program is called Dragons, Monsters and
Men.
Now, for those of you thinking maybe I can
find it on YouTube, or maybe I can find it
on Roku or Tik Tok or fire sticks or anything,
it will only be on Daily Wire.
Plus, I don't want you guys to get your hopes
up and think you're just going to be able
to go anywhere and find Jordan Peterson's
dragons, monsters and men.
Here is, I mean, a parody of himself at this
point.
Jordan Peterson's new program.
Speaker 2: One of the things I tell young
men and young women as well, but the young
men really need to hear this more.
I think you should be a monster, absolute
monster.
And then you should learn how to control it.
So a man who's capable of aggression but has
it under control is a way more useful man
than one who cannot do that.
And so you're willing to go get a job, but
you're terrified of an interview.
It's like there's a dragon for you because
you want to fight the dragons that guard the
gates of the treasure that you wish to attain.
Speaker 1: I hope you guys are particularly
the men, the women, too.
Like he says, but particularly the men.
I hope you guys are taking notes.
Why at this point?
I mean, listen, you can be you can be a good
therapist, but have personally a life that
is not going so well interpersonally.
You could be a good nutritionist, but personally
eat like crap.
Look, I think you guys get the analogy, but
at this point, Peterson's entire life is a
shambles.
That seems so sort of like, unhinged and outrageous
in every way that I don't know why people
would still be saying this is the picture
of stability and I just don't get it.
I really don't get it at this point.
It doesn't make any sense to me.
Speaker 2: Productivity requires aim, orientation,
responsibility, discipline, that willingness
to work, that willingness to make sacrifices,
which is the hallmark of maturity in the service
of a higher.
Speaker 1: Goal, even the way they have them
sitting in the chair.
If you're watching every down to the last
note, every element of this is bizarre.
Speaker 4: Or.
Speaker 2: It orients you solidly in the world
if you do that and it gives you a dragon to
fight.
Speaker 1: Right?
Speaker 2: What do you want to grow up?
You want to be illiterate.
You want to be inarticulate.
You're going to have to negotiate.
You don't have to lead.
You're going to have to convince.
You don't have to think.
If you say to a 18 year old, you're okay the
way you are.
That just deflates them.
You know, when you go to the gym and you start
lifting weights while your body's going to
transform, but it's not going to do that if
you just sit around.
You have to face your being with the necessity
of transformation and then all sorts of new.
Speaker 1: It's almost like the.
I think what at this point has become kind
of weird about all of this is.
It's gone beyond even.
It's now just approximating in the bloodiest
sense possible.
What is actually actionable advice like early
on?
There was the first layer of the Jordan Peterson
stuff where it was like, okay, he's sort of
giving specific advice, like self-help type
stuff.
And it's completely unremarkable in that it's
a lot of the same stuff that a lot of people
have been repeating for a long time.
And so to the extent that it's useful to hear
it from anybody, it might be useful.
He now just even dances around it in such
generalities that it's almost like a horoscope.
It's the horoscope version.
There has been these tests done with horoscopes
where you get people of different astrological
signs.
I don't know, are there ten or 12 of them?
And you give them all the same horoscope and
they all start to believe.
If you tell them that it's the horoscope for
their sign, that it applies to them perfectly,
even though it's just random, but it has no
meaning whatsoever.
It's sort of a similar thing where it's just
like it's the most generic possible advice
and it's so generic that people can just hear
it and they go, Yeah, that sounds reasonable,
but there's not actually anything to really
act on.
It's a very it's almost become a grift of
sorts at this point.
Speaker 2: Things that you had no idea you
were capable of will make themselves manifest.
Those are the dragons, you know, the ones
that stand in the path that leads to the light.
And you have to say to yourself, I will do
good.
Nonetheless, everyone grade makes that decision.
Make that decision because maybe you're great.
Speaker 1: The only thing missing would be
Jordan Peterson weeping now to announce this
incredible partnership.
Ben SHAPIRO interviewed, I guess, Jordan Peterson
and Ben SHAPIRO asked one question and then
Peterson just droned on and on and on.
I've never seen anything like.
I've had interview guests where it's like
close to this, but it's never been this bad.
JORDAN Obviously, this new series, Dragons,
Monsters, Men, and the first one that we're
doing together, this series is focused in
on how men can be men.
Why do you think there is such a crisis of
masculinity in the first place, and why are
there so many people out there who are angry
at you for even talking to men?
Speaker 2: Well, I think it's I think you
could think about it as a consequence in some
sense of the lack of a concept of original
sin.
Speaker 1: Right.
Now, I just dipped into it at random, like
I just clicked around, and Peterson's just
droning at every.
Speaker 2: Instant compassion that has this
devouring quality and.
Yeah.
And that's basically where we're at.
So.
Speaker 1: I found the other question SHAPIRO
was able to ask.
You know, it's one of the things that's striking
about the sort of hatred that you've gotten
from so many is that you.
Speaker 4: Literally been asked.
Speaker 1: Why you're even bothering to speak
to men.
I mean, there is this great masculinity, right?
There is this idea that so he basically asks
the same question again.
And then Peterson's just go in and go our.
Speaker 2: I'll define that as the willingness
and ability to use compulsion to attain your
aims.
Now, if you are someone who has a proclivity
to manifest power.
Speaker 1: Right.
Okay.
Here's another.
Speaker 2: One.
Power is the fundamental motivation.
And that's.
And then you think, too.
Okay.
You're only motivated by power.
That means that we can only get along if our
interests align.
Because if you're motive.
Speaker 1: Okay.
And then just one other moment.
Speaker 2: Is the manifestation of the spirit
of voluntary play.
And that's so lovely because there's nothing.
Speaker 1: All right.
I'm not going to subject you guys to more
of it, but that is the new partnership.
Jordan Peterson, who's not political and not
a right winger partnering up with the hard
right.
Media conglomerate The Daily Wire.
I'm sure it will be a fascinating show.
If any of you watch it, please let me know.
How did you survive?